hello and welcome to the weekly Fitness
football show here on Bleacher Report
brought to you by State Farm my name is
Adam Levitan of establishtherun.com
joined each and every week here by Mike
Leone
of establishtherun.com Mike how's it
going today
it's going well excited to be back for
week two
yes can't believe it they're having us
back here for week two this week we are
going to talk about some guys who dotted
in week one but we still think have a
chance to perform in week two and some
guys that we're likely starting
depending on our other options but
likely starting here in week two do not
think they are going to dud again I know
a lot of people are frustrated with some
of the way their players performed in
week one the first thing I would say is
that scoring was down massively across
the entire NFL I mean we're talking 10
or 15 touchdowns lighter than a normal
week one so it was very very very low
scoring in week one I wouldn't worry
about that it was also unique in that
there were so many injuries I mean
coming into week one there were more
injuries than usual and during the games
a lot of guys left and came back and a
lot of guys got hurt for real we'll talk
through a bunch of those here today
a guy who didn't get hurt but is playing
tonight and airballed in week one is
Dallas Goddard Leone now I think we can
explain away this guider thing pretty
easily Eagles got out to a 16-nothing
lead very quickly Patriots annually
especially since they got Kyle Duggar
but annually one of the best teams in
the league against the tight end
position after the game Eagles coaches
come out and said no no no we need to
get the ball to Dallas Goddard so man
I'm actually like excited to see what
Dallas guider does tonight I actually
think he'll be featured here
tonight in this game against the Vikings
and I don't think like Panic level on
Dallas Goddard for me right now would be
like zero maybe Leone where you at on
Dallas Goddard heading into tonight
yeah I think it's Panic level zero as
well
um it was a weird game last week just
the way this script happened with Philly
getting that early defensive touchdown
they were kind of playing from ahead it
was also not the best weather game you
know on the road to start off uh you
know the first week of the season so I'm
not concerned we've seen what this team
has their big three pass catchers with
AJ Brown Devonta Smith and Dallas
Goddard it's really concentrated on
those three guys which means there's
enough volume for all of them because
there's not a lot of ancillary targets
going elsewhere they've got a really
high team total tonight of 28 and we
actually have Goddard as a top five
option at the tight end position this
week it's it's kind of tight there
towards the back of the top five but
tight ends a really volatile position so
as bad as an airball looks I think
you've got to go back to the wild it's
pretty unlikely on most your rosters you
have a better Titan option than Goddard
oh for sure in this Minnesota secondary
I mean I know they looked okay against
the Bucks that was bigger Mayfield I
think Jalen hurts comes out and shreds a
really Talent troubled Vikings secondary
tonight
a guy that
I maybe a little bit more concerned on
T Higgins got eight Targets in the game
against the Browns and came down with
none of them now I don't even know that
any of these were catchable I mean
burrow was out of control bad the
Bengals were out of control bad it was
raining it wasn't great weather Browns
could have a really good defense this
year and I think that's also one thing
that we should know there's some very
very good defense in the NFL this year I
think the Jetstar Elite the Cowboys are
probably Elite and the 49ers might be
elite on defense Browns could be really
really good on defense too t Higgins
matchup this week is against the Ravens
what did you think of T Higgins air ball
here in week one Leone
yeah t Higgins had the fourth most air
yards in week one but we do like to call
them prayer yards because a lot of them
weren't really catchable his thing has
never really been getting a ton of
Separation but he can win kind of these
50 50 balls I think honestly I think
it's a good sign that his Target share
was up there you know Jamar Chase
obviously emerges the alpha last season
and really separated himself in Target
share from T Higgins but Higgins is
still clearly the the number two here
and that that was reestablished week one
even though the actual results weren't
there the usage was there and it was
just a horrible game you know the
Bengals couldn't block burrow looked
awful the weather wasn't great
um these things happened it was an ugly
week one across you know the the league
and if you look at other players that
were targeted and had the type of air
yards that t Higgins had you know
everybody Allen's had at least 50 yards
so I think we're going to see some
serious regression positively come
towards T higgins's way right away here
in week two it it the thing that I go
back to on T is I I think the Bengals
like him but they're not going to pay
him right and like there was a bunch of
contract stories that came out before
week one I think they like them they
just can't afford to pay them I mean
they paid Joe burrow they're gonna have
to pay Jamar Chase it's not going to be
possible really for them to pay T
Higgins also but for him to be out there
and get eight targets kind of quells any
of those fears
keep it moving here to a controversial
one Leone Christian perks so Christian
cook was very good last year I I
you know adding Calvin Ridley does two
things to Christian Kirk first cowboys
can eat up a ton of targets he's awesome
at football second when they go into
three wide receiver sets I'm sorry when
they're in two wide receiver sets they
are rolling with Zay Jones and Calum
Ridley not Christian Kurt so Christian
Kirk is getting squeezed on
how often he's on the field and he's
getting squeezed On Target chair because
Calvin Ridley is out there so I have
positive things to say about Christian
Kirk but I just want to start there on
Christian Kirk Leoni any thoughts on his
usage
yeah I'm definitely a little concerned
as someone who is super bullish on
Christian kirkhead in the end of the
year kind of my take was that like the
preseason usage and two wide receiver
sets like we don't totally know what
teams are doing and I think they're
going to be an 11 a lot anyways it's not
going to matter a ton and you know even
if Ridley has this big Target share and
is somewhat an alpha this team's gonna
throw enough to get there and cruising
curves really good and and this whole
Jacksonville offense is going to pay off
but what we saw was a combination of so
many things we saw the Ridley Alpha we
saw Kirk not playing in two wide
receiver sets we also saw the team play
more two wide receiver sets than I
expected and just run more than I
expected they also threw a Travis etn
out of the backfield a lot something
they didn't do last year so there are a
whole lot of things sort of working
together and I don't know how much of
that was games game plan specific
against like Anthony Richardson and the
Colts and maybe playing a little more
conservatively my hunch is week two here
against Kansas City they're gonna have
to play a bunch of three wide receiver
sets they're going to be thrown going a
lot more frequently more in line with
what we expected over the course this
season so I think Kirk's going to be
really up and down over the course of
the year I'm not nearly as excited for
him as I was entering week one but week
two specifically seems like the right
spot to play them
I would be playing Christian Kirk here
in week two like Leoni said they were in
three wide receiver base a lot last year
way more than they showed in week two
I'm sorry in week one
maybe that was because they weren't
playing the Chiefs and now Travis Kelsey
is going to be back Chief's going to
score a lot of points here in this game
I think we know that and they're going
to need to be an 11 base three wide
receiver base and they're gonna need
Christian Kirk out there so yeah I would
not be selling Christian Kirk right now
if you want to sell Christian I'm okay
with that but I would wait until after
this Chiefs game you're just not going
to get anything for Christian Kirk right
now
all right
um before we get to numbers four five
and six here first three guys that we
mentioned and again here we're talking
about guys who were duds in week one
that we'd we would still start in week
two first three guys we discussed were
Dallas Goddard
T Higgins
and Christian
Kirk
let's now jump Leone and you four five
and six here Josh Jacobs running back of
the Raiders faces your bills this week
by the way if you guys don't know Leone
is one of the people that jumps off of
the van's face first into the tables it
builds tailgates he's facing the bills
this week the thing for me on Josh
Jacobs is in today's NFL you do not see
running backs use the way that Josh
Jacobs is used not Christian McCaffrey
not Austin Eckler you don't see guys
getting 90 95 97 of a team's running
back touches that's what the Raiders
have been doing with Josh Jacobs for the
last two years and so I don't even think
about it Joshua that's a bad game it is
what it is when you get 90 of a team's
running back touches you're in a good
spot to bounce back at all times and I
think Josh Jacobs is like good slash
decent you know and and I think Jimmy
Garoppolo is a little bit better than
people think too so absolutely
no-brainer not for me not to worry about
Josh Jacobs doesn't mean he's gonna have
a good game here you just can't be
sitting guys in fantasy who are going to
touch the ball 15 18 20 25 times
in a game the only what do you think
about Jacobs here against Buffalo
yeah I have an expected fantasy points
model that basically just takes the
player's usage on all their individual
plays and Aggregates it and tells you
you know in general how many points
would a player have scored with this
workload
um if they were to play this game over
and over again and for week one Josh
Jacobs was actually second among all
running backs and my expected fantasy
points model he had you know five
carries inside the ten those are really
positive those green zone touches I mean
touchdowns are how you how you hit your
upside at running back at 19 carries
overall still had a few Targets in the
past game so I'm going right back to him
you know it might not be an ideal
matchup against Buffalo but as you said
there's only a handful guys that are
going to get the type of workload that
Jacobs does so can't overthink matchup
can't Panic here just because he didn't
put up double digit fantasy points week
one you got to go back to the while
oh right totally agree we have some
start sick questions from the chat I
always appreciate everyone in chat hey
prod says should I started by Loa or
Brock Purdy now everybody knows of
course that Tua was one of the best
quarterbacks if not the best quarterback
in the entire NFL here in week one Brock
Purdy I thought was also really really
really good and Brock Purdy gets a very
interesting matchup I think a good
matchup despite what happened to Geno
Smith against the Rams here Leone what
do you think about Tua vs Purdy this
week
yeah I mean it was a really good sign
that Purdy left off you know where he
was last year he weren't sure if he was
a flash in the pan or not uh all that
said I think you gotta play to uh over
Purdy almost uh all the time you know
this Miami offense is too explosive with
waddle and and Tyreek Hill to throw two
and just the way Mike McDaniel is
calling games I just think the past
volume and we saw that with the overall
yardage that Tua had and the attempts
that he had is gonna outshine what Purdy
can do even though I like both
quarterbacks yeah I mean clearly the
matchup I think it is probably better
for Purdy but I also would not overthink
it I know going to New England is not
like the cleanest spot for Tua but yeah
I definitely think that
um I would go two-way there uh keep
keeping it moving here with the chat
Jalen hurts or Joe burrow straight up I
think this is going to be an easy answer
for us all the time when you have a
choice between a guy like Jalen hurts
who can get you literally 100 yards
rushing and multiple rushing touchdowns
Anthony passing or just the guy who can
get through his yard passing it's just a
no-brainer every time it's going to be
hurts over burrow for me every time
regardless of matchup last chat here
from Del Cojo says DJ Moore or Tyler
algier so this is an interesting
reaction to week one Tyler algier
actually got more opportunities than
Bijan Robinson in that game against the
Panthers and played very well as we know
that he will run game is awesome there
DJ Moore they spent all this tried trade
capital and all this money on two
Targets for DJ Moore in week one Justin
fields looked like he has not made any
progress whatsoever as a thrower so my
first instinct is this is crazy of
course it's DJ Moore he was drafted like
10 Rounds ahead of Tyler algier in
fantasy would it be an overreaction in
week one to week one though Leoni to
start algier over DJ Moore I honestly
think it's close I think it's insane
that djmr only had two Targets in a game
where they actually threw a lot because
there's going to be games where Chicago
doesn't throw a lot and that could
happen this week where they only throw
23 24 25 times and then you know if DJ
more can't earn more than two tires I
mean obviously these Target share is
going to go up
um so I think it's closer than it should
be ultimately you know I'm gonna bet on
the talent of DJ more for another week
if the usage continues to be really
favorable for algier and really
unfavorable for more might switch that
up in week three but I think at least
one more week especially if it's a full
PPR format you gotta go with the The
Talented wide receiver here yeah I mean
at some point if the Falcons get behind
I'm not saying they're gonna get behind
against the Packers but if they do and
there's fewer running back touches to go
around algier is going to look pretty
pretty thin so yeah I'd probably I mean
we were pretty out on DJ Moore before
the season so I do not have any DJ more
on any of my teams but if I did
I think I'd go back to him here over
algier but yeah it's not looking great
for DJ Moore let's get to
some of these more week one Duds
that were thinking about starting here
in week two five six and seven here
number five on our list is Drake
London Drake London was famously
targeted just one time while Mack
Hollins got four Targets in that week
one game the truth of the matter is this
team does not want to throw the football
they want to hide Desmond Raider
and when they do throw the football it's
not like they're going out of their way
to scheme stuff for Drake London or Kyle
Pitts they scheme stuff for Cordell
Patterson who's coming back they seem to
scheme stuff for Mac Hollins
why they don't scheme stuff for Jake
London is absolutely beyond my
comprehension but it's true all that
said Leone guy's an alpha man I mean
Drake London on any other team would be
just an absolute smash guys very very
very good at football in my opinion so
what do you think about Drake London
here against the Packers
man um I'm a little concerned on this
one and I was high in Drake London
because I think like you said he's an
alpha he can earn an alpha Target share
but I also thought Atlanta would
normalize a little bit more this season
you know shame on me for thinking that
but if you listen to any of Arthur
Smith's quotes uh he really doesn't care
much about throwing the football as long
as they get the WR close and if you look
at their stats as a team from week one
they had the lowest pass rate over
expectation they're at negative 12.3
percent that means you know relative
game script down and distance that stuff
they threw the ball you know 46 of the
time but we would have expected them a
normal team they have thrown 58 of the
time so that's not a good sign their air
yards were only 63 as a team and a lot
of those went Kyle pitts's way so I'm a
little bit concerned on this one where
honestly if I had some wide receivers
that popped earlier like say flowers
popped in week one you know Jahan dots
and some of these guys
um maybe even like a Nico Collins like I
might go elsewhere I don't know I have
to think through it but um definitely
concern on London no no no don't say
that I need I need Drake one to have
good games listen they had worse
quarterback play I think and just a bit
of a scheme last year and Drake London
was still very very good I'm not ready
to give up Andre Glenn here whatsoever
and I also think yeah the Packer the
Falcons need to be pushed for Drake long
to have a good game I thought Jordan
loved looked pretty good now they're
playing in the dome here and maybe they
get some guys back maybe Dobbs is
healthier maybe buy some miracle
Christian Watson back my point is that
if the Packers get a lead and Falcons
are forced to throw it's gonna look a
lot better for Drake London so yeah as
they say flowers over Drake London is an
easy one for me but I would not play
Nico Collins over Drake one let's not be
ridiculous here uh Leone
let's go to
number six
Jamir Gibbs got massively out touched
out snapped by David Montgomery in week
one he looked awesome though quotes
after the game from Dan Campbell where
yeah Jimmy Gibbs was a rookie we didn't
give any of our rookies a lot of run
yeah blah blah blah this other nonsense
Jamir Gibbs is going to start to play
more do you believe that Leone and what
do you think about going back to Jamir
Gibbs here against the Seahawks
I think he has the potential to be such
an explosive player that I'm in on Gibbs
the usage was disappointing but like we
saw Swift with kind of similar usage
last year get there in a lot of games
you know it was sort of frustrating but
I think Gibbs is going to ultimately
have better usage than Swift had last
year and like quite frankly this is one
of the games to Target we saw this
matchup between these two teams last
year being an absolute shootout I want
to play as many you know if it's a close
sit start decision players in this game
are going to get priority for me so I'm
into Gibbs I think just a little bit
more usage and he's going to break some
big plays plus that involvement in the
passing game so nice so I'm fine you
know week one honestly wasn't that crazy
from what we expected we know they're
gonna lean on Montgomery and the way the
game went too it kind of allowed them to
play a little bit more conservatively
it's going to open up in week two yeah I
mean guy is a problem I believe he led
the NFL in broken tackles in week one
despite hardly playing I mean it's crazy
like nine touches and he led and he led
vegan in birken tackles
last guy this one this one scares me man
because I just think Matt Canada doesn't
really know what he's doing but with
Deontay Johnson out in theory in theory
George Pickens should have an elevated
Target share and I think most
importantly a different route tree than
what he's had under man Canada under
Matt Canada George Pickens mostly just
run up the sideline and get some prairie
yards and they throw it down there and
they hope you can make some crazy
contested catch and he's done that with
Deontay Johnson out
they need George Pickens winning in
different ways so maybe I'm being too
hard on my Canon maybe George Pickens
just can't do that however if I have
George Pickens I am definitely starting
him here just on the fact that Deontay
Johnson is such an elite Target earner
that has to get spread around Calvin
Austin Alan Robinson Pat Friedman are
not gonna earn targets at the rate
that Deontay Johnson would have so I'm
not excited overly about this one
but I think you have to go back to
George Pickens here any thoughts on
Steelers wide receiver stuff leonie yeah
I'm with you I think you gotta I mean if
you're not gonna play George Pickens now
it's probably not going to happen with
Deontay Johnson out definitely like a
little bit of concern that Cleveland's
defense just dominates you kind of
alluded to them being possibly one of
these awesome defenses you know given
what they did to Cincinnati in week one
but uh this is a guy who you know he's a
prospect a lot of people really liked
fell a little bit in the draft not
necessarily do Talent reasons and
the Steelers are going to have to throw
a lot you know Matt Canada might not be
great at scheming things open but at
least they're not just handing nausea at
the ball and running three yards into a
pile of dust I mean they are a little
bit but their password of our
expectation was positive week one if
they have to throw they will so the
volume should be there and it's kind of
like let's see what Pickens can do with
it as you said hopefully he's utilized
in some more creative ways with Deontay
out instead of just running fly routes
all right let's go ahead and take a few
more questions from the chat here from
DeAndre he says Jordan Addison
CD lamb or Keenan Allen in the flex so
DeAndre sounds like he has an absolutely
loaded team one of Addison lamb and
Keenan can I have your team please
DeAndre but anyways
I think the reason that people maybe are
scared of starting CD lamb here is
because Jets defense has been so good
Jets Corners are so good I don't like to
overthink it in these spots especially
with Brandon Cooks on the injury report
now with the MCL issue it would be
cd-lam there uh for me out of those
three not to take anything away from the
spots for Keen Allen and Jordan Addison
I do like the spots uh for both those
guys as well uh question two from Austin
he says Tyler Lockett or puka nakua all
right baby puka's taking over the world
Leone Tyler Lockett or puka nakua I want
to say
I don't think puka is really a fluke he
played outside he played inside I think
when Cooper Cub comes back he can still
play outside pukunuku was second in the
entire college football landscape in
yards per route run last year he's not
like some fluke weird Prospect
I don't know man puka versus Tyler
Lockett what do you think Leoni yeah but
also like 15 Target games don't just
happen that randomly that often
especially in like a normal game script
it wasn't like New England where they
were chucking for three and a half
quarters against Philly because of the
game script so to get 15 targets and
like a pretty normal game where they
actually had the lead most of the second
half was really impressive for puka so I
think this one's actually extremely
close our projections have it really
close I would probably in like a season
long managedly give the slight
tiebreaker to some more certainty with
Tyler Lockett I also mentioned really
wanting to Target this Seattle Detroit
game so I think I'd go lock it but we
literally in in pure projection had them
you know right next to each other so I
think you know puka is legit he's
someone I spent a bunch on in Fab to get
on my teams so
um you know it's it's a good decision to
have to make for your team but I'd
slightly lean lock it here
of course from Norman and Chad he says
notice Naji Harris is not on this list
you wouldn't give him a second chance in
week two so the reason that we
overlooked Naji Harris here Norman is we
do not own any nor uh Naji Harris on any
of our teams because uh we were
completely out on Naji Harris just based
on him not being that good at football
offensive line being major problem and
Jalen Warren arguably being better and
going to take snaps and that's kind of
the way we saw it play out in week one
offense was disaster Jalen Warren played
a ton the difference though is they were
playing San Francisco it was a tough
spot but they played Cleveland again
this week certainly not a great spot for
Naji so the thing of running back is
it's hard to have like a lot of better
options than someone who's going to
touch the ball 10 to 15 times like Naji
will right so I wouldn't be excited
about it but I might go back to him what
do you think about Naji this week
yeah I mean it's like it's similarly
tough spot is week one like this team is
an underdog against a really good
defense and when you're playing an
inefficient back who is now seating some
work to the backup in a spot where we're
worried about the offense like
that's not a good spot to be in I think
Naji is going to have his games when the
the offense itself performs in these
easier matchups and he can get there
just on the volume he can get some short
touchdowns you know you can get up to 18
carries or so
um but I don't see that being the spot
this week you know we've got him for
like 12 PPR points so it's a fine
projection as you said there aren't a
ton of backs that are going to project
better than that but it's more like
Fringe rb2 than it is a locked in rb1 I
mean there's better if you were looking
to like move on from Naji I'd probably
wait till he plays the Raiders in week
three and the Texans in week four maybe
he can do something there and you'll be
able to get something for him at that
point
last one here Mets fan Abby says would
you start Jalen hurts or Kirk Cousins
tonight I have both yeah that's a
no-brainer there again if you have a
pocket pastor and you're comparing him
to Jalen hurts there is absolutely no
debate what so
ever
all right Hertz is our top projected
scoring quarterback of all the
quarterbacks so if your question has to
do with Jalen hurts the answer is Jalen
hurts all right
speaking of Jalen hurts let's jump into
the fantasy bundles presented by our
friends at State Farm we're bundling
your home and auto shirt insurance is
just another way to save with the
personal price plan
State Farm Insurance all right the State
Farm bundles for week two the first one
we actually wanted to highlight was when
we've already been talking about
Jalen hurts to Dallas Goddard now
talked about the squeaky wheel stuff and
we just talked about how with Dallas
guider coming off the air balls squeaky
wheel they already talked about
featuring him and you have Jalen hurts
in a bounce back spot against a really
weak Vikings defense and he's playing at
home absolute smash I think here for the
bundle tonight if you told me who's
gonna score more points like this one or
cousins versus Justin Jefferson I would
say that cousins Justin Jefferson would
score more but not like 100 of the time
probably not even like 80 of time maybe
you know 55 60 percent of the time or
something like that so really like the
spot tonight for Jalen hurts and Dallas
Goddard Leone we already talked about
that one so maybe we should move on
with Justin Herbert and Keenan Allen
here I think the game plan for the
Chargers week one was like somewhat
matchup specific they actually ran a lot
more than we expected them to but their
Pace was still really good so look for
them to pass more aggressively week two
Tennessee's a bit of a past funnel
defense they've got a really Stout
defense against the run and force his
teams to throw more frequently and I
think the Chargers are a smart enough
organization like they're gonna do what
works against the defense that they're
facing so combine that with really Up
Tempo and you know Herbert Keenan I
think are pretty locked in for a high
volume day
I really like this one you know like
Leoni said I don't think they're a
little bit of a pass model I think
they're a massive pass funnel I mean
their defensive front is very good their
secondary is not very good also I would
know for Keenan Allen it's not great for
Keenan and Eckler in the past game when
they're both out there they kind of play
in the same areas and they soak up a lot
of targets together Austin Eckler could
miss this week with an ankle issue we'll
see if he does I think that helps Keenan
Allen a lot in terms of how much volume
he will see
third one here is the Buffalo Bills Josh
Allen and Gabe Davis we saw Steph Diggs
have a bit of an alpha game against the
Jets in a tough matchup now they get a
much easier matchup and to me these are
like the spots where you can get Gabe
Davis
going hopefully I think the bills kind
of think Gabe Davis isn't that good but
they don't have that much of a choice
other than to play home on every snap
they just don't have anyone else to put
out there that's not the best ring
endorsement for Gabe Davis when you're
playing the Raiders I think I think you
have a chance at least so what do you
think about Gabe this week and Josh
Allen here against the Raiders yeah you
know that wasn't the Hard Sell but it is
a get right spot for Buffalo after the
collapse week one and to your point
though Gabe Davis ran the most routes of
any player on the Buffalo Bills one more
than Stephan Diggs here on 47 routes
according to Pro Football Focus that's
96 route participation lines up with
what we saw last week they do not have
anybody else to play that outside wide
receiver spot now teams have been more
conscious of taking away that deep ball
that Gabe Davis gives them you know the
last season or so but he still has that
really big play potential he's a tall
reliable Red Zone Target so
um he's someone that can get there and
four you know four catches four really
big plays so I'm definitely down with
this pairing yeah you know it's hard I
just tweeted an article you can follow
me at Adam Levitan on Twitter I just
tweeted an article about this new
defensive Trend in the NFL or newish
defensive Trend everybody playing these
two high safeties too high safe too high
safety it's not great for guys like Gabe
Davis right if everybody's gonna play
two high safeties it's not great for for
Gabe Davis at all so that's just
something I'm watching but I do think
it's a pretty good spot here for Gabe
Davis
fourth bundle Gino Smith and DK Metcalf
so this game last year both teams scored
over 40 points when the Seahawks and
lions played Gino was
awful shockingly awful against the Rams
in week one if this game does go nuts
though and I think it certainly has a
chance to that's what happens when these
games happen in Detroit I think DK
Metcalf has to be a big part of it for
the Seahawks so what do you think about
Gino's chances of a bounce back here
Leone with Metcalf yeah I mean I think
we had him as a bundle last week I know
I played him in my DFS lineups and it
was a huge let down not sure what
happened I'm keeping my eye on the
offensive line injuries for Seattle it
seemed like they really had some issues
after a couple guys left that game early
so I'm gonna keep my eye on that but
ultimately like you said this game
environment against Detroit is just so
good that I don't think it matters too
much and Metcalf is the bigger play wide
receiver and more importantly he's the
reliable Red Zone Target for Gino down
there so I like it
um you know frustrated with how it went
last week but I'm gonna give Gino
another week before I start to panic on
him
last bundle here Anthony Richardson and
Michael Pittman I mean I don't think it
could have gone much better from a
fantasy perspective in week one for
Anthony Richardson not only did they
give him six designed runs not only did
he get two carries from inside the five
yard line but also he completed 65 of
his passes and yeah a lot of them were
short
and and
they played the fastest Pace in the
league and
and they had a first down throw rate
that was eighth best in the league I
mean this was like
really optimistic in my opinion for
Anthony Richardson so yeah I would be
super excited about having him right now
um and quite frankly I like I didn't
really take Michael Pittman much if at
all uh in the season-long process and
I'm I don't know if I'm regretting that
as much as I would be regretting not
having Anthony Richardson but yeah if it
go if he does well in the air I think
it's almost certainly through Pitman
what do you think about this one Leone
yeah it was a full send for Richardson
week one we lost a couple prop bets on
unders for Anthony Richardson because we
did not expect him as you said to
complete passes at the rate that he did
but also the play calling they had a 68
pass rate in this game they were
slightly positive over expectation
combined that with the pace and we
already knew that one positive for
Pitman we knew coming in was just like
this style of offense sometimes you're
going to get a guy with a really high
Target share with something like the RPO
stuff and whatnot he had the 28 Target
share we just didn't think the volume
that we saw in week one would be there
or the completion rate so now that
there's at least a chance that both
those things are going to stick around
you know Pittman's fan he's one of the
guys the fantasy stock for me has gone
way up since prior to week one where I
thought it could be more of like what we
saw with DJ Moore and Drake London
all right we got a couple more minutes
here we'll wrap up with some questions
from chat throw says DeAndre Swift or
Alexander Madison tonight it's an
interesting question I mean Alexander
Madison's workload was awesome in week
one just like we expected I have
efficiency concerns on his iron medicine
in this spot against the Eagles but I
don't even know what to expect from
Kenny gamewell I mean I'm sorry from
DeAndre Swift I understand Kenny
gamewell's out how do we know that
Rashad Penny's not gonna be the man
tonight or or Boston Scott's gonna be
the man at the goal line
tonight and so for me I would just take
the reliability in the Touches for
Madison over Swift tonight which I know
stinks because in theory like you want
to be playing the under Swift now while
Kenny gamewell is out right but what do
you think about this one Leoni Swift
versus Madison
yeah I think I'm with you on this one I
guess like if you really feel like
they're gonna go fully to Swift like
Swift with the same workload as Madison
would be clearly the play here the team
that's going to score more points the
more efficient back not close but
he might not even lead the Philly
backfield in touches and there's a lot
of risk there so I think I'm with
Madison unless you're just really in the
mood to gamble on on the pure up side of
Swift miles says is saquon Barkley gonna
bounce back yeah I mean the Giants just
didn't show up I mean no one on the
Giants showed up whatsoever then this
week they get to play the Cardinals like
saquon be one of my favorite guys to
play this week I would not be worried
about Sequon Matt Vera says he's stuck
on his backs Javonte Williams as a new
Madison or Rashad white he needs to
bench one of them
I'd say this on Javonte Williams
it looks reasonably healthy to me and
they are really involving their backs in
the past game including jonte Williams
so that is a very very good sign a
reasonable spot for Javonte here home
against the commanders Rashad white on
the other hand like does not look very
good not very very efficient I think
their run game is probably broken but he
played a ton I mean he played like 80 of
the snaps and we already talked about
Madison so this is a tough one the only
way you think bench one of Javonte
Madison Rashad White
man this is a really tough one you know
my gut instinct was to say Rashad white
but it is a more favorable matchup and
as you said that workload was so good
week one so like I have these serious
long-term concerns about Rashad white
holding on to this job but I think if I
had to bench one
um with Denver going up against a good
Commander's defense some comments about
wanting to play actually the third
running back there McLaughlin I'm gonna
I'm gonna say bench Javonte here but
um it's tough because you're starting
Madison and white are two guys where
they're very workload dependent neither
of them are efficiency guys but I'm
gonna go with them given that Javonte
has a tough matchup anyways yep all
right last one we're gonna do here today
Aztec Thunder did you just miss Schuster
or Terry McLaren so I got bad news uh
Aztec Thunder Juju might be dusted man
I'm sorry to say it he might just be
done seems like the knee is still a
problem report today out of New England
said the Patriots might view Juju Smith
Schuster as their fifth best past
catching option we're including Hunter
Henry Michael sticky in there Kendrick
Bourne looked really good last week
Devonte Parker could be back so I don't
think you can start Juju Smith Schuster
period right like I don't care who you
said and Terry McLaren is a good player
man so yeah I think it's a no-brainer
Terry mcclory like if you had to drop
JuJu at this point
I wouldn't hate you for it man I mean it
looks real bad for Juju right now and by
the way you're not the only one that may
have had a bad Talent about on Juju
Smith Schuster the Patriots let Kobe
Myers walk and gave Juju Schuster a very
very similar contract which is proving
to look very very stupid
all right
that is gonna do it for this week's
Bleacher Report fantasy football show
brought to you by State Farm remember we
don't need to overreact to week one we
also don't need to under react there was
a lot of stuff to react to a lot of the
usage stuff some of the stuff like T
Higgins dial Scott and air balls saquon
Barkley that's the stuff I wouldn't
worry about too much
thanks so much for having us and
everyone at The Bleacher Report Team
thanks so much to everyone for tuning in
if they have us back we'll be back next
week four
Mr Leone you can follow him on Twitter
at two hats1 Mike follow me at Adam
Leviton and by the way if you're serious
about fantasy football you got to be on
Twitter I'm not just saying that to pump
my own bags you got to be on Twitter
that's where all the best Facebook
information is for Leone
for me Adam for everyone behind the
scenes at Bleacher Report good luck
everybody